der Wolf ist da rund 180 tierstreifen
durch Schweiz und es werden immer mehr
in der Berge ist es Riesenthema man
spürt Angst Wut und Hilflosigkeit und
wegen Wolf gibt es ein dicker zwischen
Berg und Stadt
wenn sie sagen den Computer funktioniert
das so sage ich auch nicht stoppt leider
funktioniert das
das Thema ist hochpolitisch und
emotional vor allem mit der
Landwirtschaft für Leute
aber der war dein Fehler
ja
[Musik]
Dilemma der Wolf richtet
und andere Tier statt selber aber unter
Schutz 12 wo Probleme machend
also für mich jetzt Journalist ist es
sehr schwierigste Thema irgendwie ich
bin der doofen aufgewachsen und
verstorben alte Problem aber Chöre auf
viele Gegenargument für den Wolf aus der
Stadt aber der Wolf beschäftigt nicht
nur BürgerInnen und purer sondern auch
dir
regelmäßig wird es dir in Dörfer
gesichtet also
ja und das das sind denn die Moment wo
man den UI Techno
wie ich es zum Deutsch schaffen und
Leber wo auch der Wolf sich quartiert
hat und was macht das mit der Leute und
genau das Gott in der Reportage
Mini Hartig zum Wolf
schwierig ich finde eine Sitze
in der Schweiz aber gesehen wirklich
auch die andere Seite und die wird
behaupten
Thema auf Facebook und Stammtisch in den
Nachrichten und jetzt Gefühl viele wo
vielleicht eher in städtischer Regionen
wohnen und so und hat wieder weg sind
vom Wolf die realisieren gar nicht was
das mit einem macht wenn man da ein Wolf
vor der Haustür hat und um genau das
Gott sie den Film es wird aber mit um
Politiker wir werden doch nicht pro und
contentiere wenn du zu dem Wort mehr
fahren ich verlinke dir der una in der
Beschreibung
es wird eigentlich nicht
ja und Menschen wo du mein Land lebend
was macht das mit denen und deshalb bin
ich dort snufenen im Kanton Graubünden
einer von vielen Ärzten viele Jahre mit
dem Wolf zu Hand und mit suchend Familie
also wo genau sie wie ich das gesehen
ja was ist was ist passiert ist ich bin
dahin mit dem Bob es wird besser ab und
dann nicht da so
Hinterteil
ganz normaler Hund und wo ich heiraten
bin ist der schlussendlicher und da bin
ich halt gerade witzig
wie heißt das denn also du hast keine
check das ist ein Wolf in der Moment
das hätte ich gemacht wenn es Check
tätig denn
und wer zu der Frau aufgesetzt
[Musik]
und sie sind Emotionen aufkochen vor
allem mit der sozialen Medien
und das wohl agriffen
sehr sehr selten sind und trotzdem
Instagram gelandet oder und
eigentlich Grad also ja und das das sind
denn der Moment wo man den Schnee
am Morgen gesehen
ja und das sind dann schon die Momente
ist der Schlittelweg und
Tag und denn ist schon immer ganz wohl
wilde Tiere
[Musik]
man muss mit Respekt
auf der Schulweg während
sicher nicht noch ihren provozierenden
[Musik]
selber
ja und das ist in dem Moment den
vielleicht gleich Angst hält die schaue
nochmal aber das weiß er kann ihn da
aber in jedes husina und sie regierend
sich er kann nicht sagen also es wird
auch
mal wieder reißt zweimal mehr halt die
Schuhe weg nachher dass er einfach mit
der sicher ist
also danke dir mach's gut
danke ciao
es ist Respekt wo der Oma ist und es ist
tatsächlich so dass der Wolf Öffis mit
dem Dorf oder mit der Region gemacht
hätte man denkt öfter darüber nach und
man weiß er ist da aber ich glaube aber
Panik und Angst dass das gibt's
echt cool also auch Elia der Sohn
recht cool
emotionaler ist Diskussionen
zum Beispiel Büren empura oder hirtener
und Hirter und das
und für das bin ich für ihr Ufer den
wunderschönen Herbsttag
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt da irgendwo ob Klosters
im Prättigau in Graubünden und da
irgendwo ist Nomi auf der Haut gesehen
es ist schon ihre siebte Summe auf der
Alpsee das Jahr
auch
wegen Wolf früher als Sauce
und fahren das Stück wieder auf damit
süße Witze
auf der Alb Täter vom Wolf beschützen
schlagziele zum Wolf wo auf der alt
Nutztier Christa
jede Summe werden es mehr schon nur dass
sie auch sind rund 450 nutzt der
gerissen waren im Kanton Graubünden
Luther Behörde viele Hirte sind
verzweifelt und immer wieder gehört
es durch Thema
[Gelächter]
ja ich denke ermittelmaß wäre okay also
keine Ahnung ich denke nicht dass man
alles ganz muss weg nee aber halt
regulieren dass man deinen Griff hat
regulärer ist eben nicht erlaubt 12
gelten als geschützte Tier und will man
sie nur ausnahmsweise
aber das noch nie Klapptisch das ist
recht hart ist oder nicht da wohl durch
meine also für die was gern machen es
ist hart aber
gewohnt was ist denn
hart da auf der Alb also jetzt für mich
das sind keine
Verträge und
Kilo und wenn der Name so ein Rucksack
voll und da überall muss
Entschädigung vom Bund und Kanton für
jedes Tier im jeweiligen Marktwert
im 2 19 Händler so insgesamt
272000 Franken
da ganz oben Waldgrenze ist Nomi der
Sommer auf der Alpsee das Gebirge ist
riesig und sehr wetläufig mit 700
Hektaren
und dann berührt sie sich
in der Schweiz wo auch nicht Leber und
was ja verständlich
auf jeden Fall es ist deswegen mir ja
auch nicht dass er also es geht auch
beides aber wie gesagt aber
ich denke auch da aber also dass man im
Griff hat und das nicht irgendwie die
ganze Schweiz nachher sich nach dem Wolf
richten muss und alles
sicher gemacht werden muss was macht das
mit deren halt
wenn es vielleicht nicht genau checken
wie es ist und deswegen
Computer funktioniert das so sage ich
auch nicht stoppt leider funktioniert
das obwohl ich ja keine
und vielfach halt keine Ahnung das
Gefühl also ich weiß es nicht
aber da hinten hat viel zu quasi sie
wissen nicht so genau wie das abläuft
und der Wolf der ist nur das was wir
dann halt auch Frucht und und
Probleme
und so Sachen halt und der Baby gesagt
und
mit dem Wolf und hat auch was das mit
dir gemacht hätte
und
sie Nebenweg seit scharfgerissen worden
[Musik]
und ja da ist ein bisschen aber
am Anfang
[Musik]
aber übrigens
das ist dann auch kein Problem denke
Dir wo Du mal leise mit Steinschlag
Blitzschlag und das ist einfach
natürlich
wäre mit deiner mit einer 45 oder so
aber
und überall und
ich einfach so nimm zu Ausmaß ab wo dann
halt für die für die Beteiligte
ja es ist natürlich schon
du ja also
ich habe
[Musik]
ja
so ähnlich kann es auch von mehrere
andere
mehr real bin Graubünden sind das Jahres
und es wichtig für Schweizer Landschaft
will weg der dir wachsen talpen mit i
omez
unter anderem auch willst den seltener
agriffen
krass ich könnte das gar nicht und als
nächstes können wir zu der Nora
sie hat auch schon aber hobbymäßig also
so 30 40 Stück und auch ihre Alp kommt
das ja ein bisschen
Telefon gemerkt
ist der Stress
Gesicht vor der Nora strahlt endlich
kann sie ihre Chefkoch abholen sie hat
aktuell rund 30 davon und puret neben
ihrem Bürojob wenn du am wenigstens
wir laufen das damals im und
angefangen hat
und manchmal neue Leute in Kontakt
kommen
Reaktionen sind in aller Regel positiv
geschieht Leute
was machst denn mit denen und untersten
augenli oder was machst du mit der Bulle
seit ganz vielen Themen ergeben
und mittlerweile ist es so dass es
ja gar nicht
fremd will Reaktion ist viel mal gerade
zuerst hätte nicht Angst vor dem Wolf
und einfach die Rhetorik
logisch aber
ja es ändert wir nicht
[Musik]
und jetzt darüber werden alle Schaf von
der Alp wurde
Arbeit der Ober sind ganz viele
purer und labortierten
alles gut letzte Nacht
okay Wochenende
und extra für mich hängt Buren oder das
Plakat montiert rettet Alben
auf Social Media und in der Media
probiert Landwirtschaft in der Berge
Problematik zu erklären wirklich
nachvollziehen
sie mir
also für mich
ist es sehr schwierigste Thema irgendwie
und ich probiere jetzt halt wirklich zum
mits Thema Wolf besprechen sondern eher
das Thema Mensch und hat Frage was es
mit ihnen macht also was das jetzt mit
der Nora macht der Donau
Betrieb gehört
für sie sind das nicht nur x-schaf jedes
einzelne
Bezug zu ihnen zwei für ihre Chef können
ja ja natürlich aber
das ist jedes einzelne wichtig und
sind eigentlich Zuchtlinien wo man über
mehrere Jahre betreut und häht jedes
Jahr sagt man wieder ein paar Lämmer aus
wo man paltet wo man auch er nimmt wo
man nicht verkauft und ja wenn dann halt
gerade zwei gerissen werden
wo auch miteinander
besonders betreut hat der hängt man
einfach so
aber der wo den Fehler
nirgendsmeister
[Musik]
Problematik ist oder nicht auf dass ich
da niemand mehr Bock aber wo ich Grenze
zwischen Realität und Alltag mit dem
Wolf und anti wolfspopaganda ich kann es
echt nicht zeigen
X10 oder Chöre von vielen Emotionen also
verwurt über über drüber ja
Hilflosigkeit auch also was macht das
Ganze mit dir das ganze Thema Wolf oder
the wolf of was macht das mit dir
mit
trödigkeit oder will
ich kann gerne Militär oder und
ja Hilflosigkeit meine schädelflosse
dagegen man kann nie machen und das
Thema Staaten natürlich
und man dann im Vorhinein
aber nicht Rezept alle enthunger aber
nehmen
kein Tag wenn man kein mehlig überkommt
jetzt
im taldo ist denn der Druck wo deines
so jeder Morgen nicht was trifft
schlecht
oder Möglichkeit noch eine größer dass
der nächste Morgen
das ist dann der Druck wo entsteht und
das ist gerade im Wolf der Druck
entsteht der ganze Familie vom
klick-kind bis zum Grossvater in der
ganz Familie und zuschauerprobleme vom
Landwirtschaftsbetrieb oder so gibt es
mit Betriebsleiter und gelöst und da
Gott der ganz Familie einfach durch das
gibt Druck auf die ganze Familie denn
es gibt übrigens auch die Leute in der
Landwirtschaft wo das mit dem Wolfen
nicht so kritisch sind es sind private
mal nicht alle vom Wolf betroffen da ist
aber niemand Fan
inzwischen sind Chef mit dem N für Nora
aussortiert zieht zum zurück ins Tal
Arbeitsgericht
[Musik]
und ihrem Partner
dann ist ja verständlich dass es so
dass die ganze Wurf Thematik halt so
Emotionen
hervorragend
für mich das merkt jeder verstorben
[Musik]
einfach nur noch funktioniert ja sie hat
gesagt
und dann fassen wir kadaverius und du
jetzt das nur noch aber und der Kopf
oder ist einfach ja so krasse Bilder und
irgendwie Speicher ist im
Unterbewusstsein
also wenn du sagst euch einfach
funktioniert oder
hättest dir denn wenn ich zu den fahre
wenn ich zu realisiert und und und
ich glaube das ist ja verschiedene
oder irgendwer öffentlich machen will es
will einfach niemand gesehen und das ist
oder hässlich und
ja weil ich natürlich einfach traurig um
die lämmert und sie fehlen den Halt also
was wo wir den salp sind mit denen Schaf
oder eine WK hat
irgendwo wo ist denn der Rest und den
Eier
[Musik]
wir machen Stromnetze aus der Tourer
Radio ich Schalter permanent im Stall
das einfach so
[Musik]
aber ich glaube es ist alles mehr zum
meet beruhigen dass ich sage wenn ich da
50 Meter weiter im Haus bin und schlafe
dass sie einfach denke wie ich scharf
sind aber sicherer Ort aber ob es denn
sicher ist oder nicht
ja ich hoffe nicht dass mal so weh tun
aber das wäre letztendlich
also wenn du wolltest ja wahrscheinlich
keine mehr über Winter sind da ungefähr
20 scharf
und ja ich glaube wenn der Maler da
ihnen ist
und dann habe ich verschiedene
ja für mich ist es nicht erledigt in dem
wenn jetzt für die auch nur die Hälfte
von meiner Härte verlieren wenn ihr dann
einfach zehn andere Schafe bekommen oder
das Geld oder das interessiert mich
entnehmen und der Meister praktisch alle
Generationen und denn ja hast du einfach
nicht so ersetzen
genau
ein prothetische Frage
wenn also ja irgendwo böse kriegt gehört
und ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt
aber das purer oder Hirter einmal selber
ich sage mal sich verteidigt
wenn du jetzt Möglichkeit hättest
theoretisch
wenn jetzt die Situation so ist dass der
Wolf da im Minus schafft innen ist und
Hälfte ist schon tot und die haben
Chance und die andere Hälfte aber jetzt
mit der Mistgabel oder mit der schufler
weniger der Roller oder also ja ich
halte das für uns geschlossen dass ihr
mal in der so eine Situation kommen oder
ich hoffe es auch aber ja im Notfall mit
dem
sackmesserverteidiger also ja muss
irgendwie
[Musik]
so zurück von der Berge in der Stadt was
nehme ich mit ich glaube der Wolf ganz
abschießen
das schon deswegen sogar
Naturschutzorganisationen inzwischen
frage ich jetzt einfach nur wir und
genau das wird momentan sperren im
Parlament besprochen mit Revision vom
Jagdgesetz aber deren Diskussion es gibt
ein Stadt Landgraben das ist ganz klar
und ich frage mich mit Situation wäre
wenn es umgekehrt wäre wenn es also kein
Wölfe die Berge hätte sondern der
Krokodil im Zürichsee was jetzt aber
wirklich gelernt hat in der Reportage
ich kann nachvollziehen wieso raubt ihr
von der Haustür ja Sorger oder Angst
könnte bereiten das Verstauen die
absolut aber was sie auch lernen kann
ist dass man nur wenn man sich Sorgen
macht ums Thema Wolf ist mir nicht
automatisch
es ist also nicht alles Schwarz und Weiß
und das ist
[Musik]
Reportage was meinst du kannst du dir
Sorger oder Herausforderungen
schreibt mir gerne Kommentare und wenn
du noch mehr Videos von Records denn
abonniere doch neueste Kanal und auf der
Seite Video verlinkt über der Wolf wen
er tickt sehr sehr spannend lockt doch
mal drei und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
Mal